hey everyone its Johanna here I want to
get you ready to wear backless outfits
so for today's workout we will be
working on our lower back I will meet
back and our upper back working on your
back also help with your posture to
stand upright and appear taller so for
this workout we will need two sets of
dumbbells one much heavier dumbbell
between four to six kilos each and one
much lighter dumbbell only one to two
kilos each so let's start the workout so
prep your heavier dumbbells the first
workout is called deadly and this is
going to work on our lower back I want
you to stand shoulder width apart keep
your dumbbells close to your legs keep
your knees soft and bed down from your
waist keeping the pelvis close to your
knees and squeeze your little back up
and stand upright and squeeze your pump
at the same time so let's try it again
bring the dumbbells down back from your
waist come up squeeze the low back and
squeeze your bum so this workout is not
only working on your lower back and your
core but it is also working on your
hamstrings and your body all right so
let's do 20 each let's go keep your
knees soft bring the dumbbells down and
up so let's count one two down and
squeeze it up good let's go remember to
open your chest keep your chest open and
squeeze throw me a little back so the
spring should come from your lower back
and you should feel your lower back work
no hanji good keep going down as low as
you can and squeeze up so really go down
as low as you can
Anna good keep going then leaves is one
of the best workout for your lower back
your core and your legs okay very nice a
strong lower back equals a stronger body
good so push your bum out keep your body
upright open up your chest and squeeze
good I want you to really squeeze your
pump on the way up so we are working on
multiple muscles at the same time keep
going let's go eight more squeeze let's
turn up a little back good up so
remember weights should always be close
to your body nice then we're down up
that's five down squeeze up stand
shoulder width apart squeeze good do
your lower back working squeeze very
nice three more down squeeze remember to
keep your knees soft throughout no
tension on the knees good and last one
and up very good second workout fans
overall this is for your mid-back so
same thing keep your knees soft and
shoot it with apart bring the dumbbells
down and squeeze it up to feel your
mid-back so what I want you to make sure
is that your elbows are always close to
your body so try not to open it instead
keep it close to your body all right
palms facing down let's do 20 as well so
bring it down keep up check upright and
up good one - very good
three four five meat reoffending for
your waist six and and know without
seven the lower you go eight the more
you will feel good if you're standing
too tall you will only be working and
feeling your shoulders
good let's go ten more two three four so
really bend from your waist five good
keep the posture straight six seven and
drive it and feel it in your arms and
your back last two up up
very good so that workout was to work on
your mid-back
No drop the heavy dumbbell press the
light dumbbell and this is for your
upper back and trust me if you're
working out the back you have a really
nice show this as well this is concrete
let's fly so we want to get back into
the same position sugar knees soft
bend your knees keep your body upright
bring the weights in front of you in
line with the chest and what we're going
to do is to open it imagine applying and
feel your upper thighs working squeeze
the upper back and bring it back down so
not too low but always try to keep it
chest level okay so this is top that's
why we are using really light weight so
open it squeeze it through your lower
back upper back sorry close it and
squeeze it okay so bring it up
yup one good job back from your
waistline a smell - very nice three open
your arms straight or relaxed elbows
five so a slight bend on your elbows
good keep going
is not an easy workout because our upper
back muscles are really small good keep
going halfway there if you're struggling
what you can do is spend more on your
elbows or trade this way let's go ignore
open really for your upper back working
good keep going one two four more three
squeeze really open up last three open
last two one and one more good jump but
do you feel you're working that was a
really good workout for your upper back
your biceps and your shoulders as well
so let's do all the workouts again and
let's try not to rest between sets okay
grab your heavier dumbbells get into
your back position that's what I like to
call it and let's start with deadly
ready
shut up with a part time from your waist
let's go relax your knees go 20 times up
one squeeze your bum to really feel a
little back your bum and hamstrings
working so arch a little bit to view on
your lower back good five very nice as
low as you can
thanks really go all the way down if you
can seven down eight very nice nine good
always stand tall and squeeze the lower
back and squeeze your buttock halfway
there good keep going
remember to keep the dumbbells close to
your legs dude - so really your arms
should be relaxed
and the power should drive from your low
back
eight more keep going good squeeze
squeeze very nice
let's get six more one two and straight
into bent over row three last three or
doing it five and six back down let's
get into bent over rows one two so Elvis
close three four good job let's work on
the mid back turn your meat back up five
six very nice seven keep coming open up
your chest then from your waist nine ten
halfway there one two very nice good
three four remember to bend your knees
slightly
five squeeze six squeeze seven eight
last two nine ten drop the heavy
dumbbells grab your light dumbbells
let's go into reverse fly okay ready one
so really squeeze and feel your upper
back make sure it's in line with your
chest three good job for it's not easy
five six squeeze good slow it down for
seven slow it down eight nine
so when you bring it back control the
weights ten good one
slow it down - let's work for the nice
upper back to an upper back and nice
shoulders biceps
choices six more one two all right keep
your body fat three check up for last
two five six good good job
we're all done so that was three really
simple and effective back exercises to
work on your lower meat and upper back I
love back exercises because it gives you
a really nice and strong posture do
three to four sets
try not to rest in between exercises and
only run up to one minute in between
sets as you get stronger as you progress
add more weights and in no time you will
be rocking a backless top all the mass
for new fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]
you
[Music]